[Informal Talk]
I first met Richard Scrushy in the summer of 1980. I was
living in Houston Texas and I had recently passed the CPA
exam and I wanted to go to work for a large company, a
publicly held company; I had always worked for rather small.
And I answered an ad in the paper and it was for a
controller position at Lifemark Corporation; Lifemark was a
publicly held hospital company. And I went in for the
interview and it was with Richard Scrushy and I had never
met anybody quite like Richard. All during the interview my
head was just spinning I just couldn't believe the person
that he was and by the end of the interview I was totally
convinced that that was the best job I could possibly get in
Huston Texas. But as I was driving home I kept thinking
about the interview and when I got home I told my wife I
said I think today I have met the most brilliant businessman
I am ever going to meet or may be the biggest con artist I
will ever meet, and that's actually been quoted in the Wall
Street Journal and the New York Times and a lot of other
publications. But he did, he offered me the job, I reported
to work. I got to work, my first day I was there about 30
minutes early and he came into my office and he said Aaron,
he said, I am presenting a contract to my boss and I would
like you to sit in on my presentation, it's a contract I
think we should sign. And I went in, he introduced me to his
boss and he said Aaron and I worked on this contract for
hours last night and I hadn't worked on anything, I had
barely stepped in front door. And today, I realize that he
probably told that lie to size me up, to see how I would
react to being included in the lie. At that time I didn't
think that much about it but I know more about Richard
Scrushy now and I am sure that he told that lie on purpose.
I worked for Richard for almost four years at Lifemark. We
managed departments within hospitals. We would contract with
hospital to run their respiratory therapy, physical therapy,
and pharmacists and Richard was just amazing. He could go
into a little hospital in Arkansas or somewhere and walk in
and walk out with three contracts to run big revenue centers
in their hospitals and would take a percent of the money.
But I also learned that he had a real dark side, he was so
into himself and I remember many times sitting in his office
and he would be ranting and raving about a problem he was
having with his ex-wife or his boss and it was always about
Richard, never about me, always about him. In the summer of
1983, I picked up the Wall Street Journal a morning, read
and it said Lifemark to be acquired by AMI, a much larger
hospital company out of California. And the article said
they would be closing the offices of Lifemark and I thought
oh no man, I am going to be without a job. But what happens
many times, these were two New York stock exchange companies
and a lot of times when they merge, a venture capitalist
will approach, the company's being bought out and Lifemark
was clearly being bought out and Citicorp Venture Capital
contacted Bill Mackey, the chairman of the board, and asked
him, does anybody have an idea for a startup company that
they could back and Bill Mackey said Richard Scrushy without
a doubt. So we made him a full VP when he was only 26 years
old and he's been talking to us about getting into the
outpatient business. Back in the early 80s if you had an
accident or you needed physical therapy after a surgery, the
physician would just keep you in the hospital as an in-
patient and you would receive your therapy as an in-patient.
Even back then the cost of health care was a big concern.
Richard's concept was get the patient out of the hospital as
fast as you can, or certainly eliminate the room and board
portion of the hospital bill and the patient would rather go
home and go back as an outpatient rather than staying in a
building full of sick people and he felt like the therapist
would rather work in that kind of environment rather than in
the hospital itself. In a hospital, the doctors and the
nurses are kind of the big dudes, the therapy departments
are kind of off in the basement somewhere and don't get that
much recognition and Richard felt like if you put them in
their own freestanding outpatient center they will like
working there better. He convinced Citicorp to put a million
dollars into his startup company and he wanted me to be his
CFO to help build a company that hopefully one day would go
public. But I didn't want to, I had had about enough of
Richard. He just glares down on you and he manages by
intimidation and I really kind of wanted to get away from
him even at that point. But he said look Aaron, he said put
in $5,000 you would get a 100,000 shares of stock, nickel a
share. He said I am putting in $25,000 I am going to get
500,000 shares and you have got to realize Citicorp is
paying a dollar a share for their million shares so today
your nickel is already worth a dollar. And I didn't have a
job, I was going to be laid off and I believed Richard could
do it, I was impressed that he got Citicorp to put a million
dollar in him, and it was almost on the back of an envelope,
they had already cut the deal, no formal business plan or
anything. And I felt like he really could run a big company
and take it public so I said okay I am in.
Richard was from Alabama. He was born and raised in Selma
Alabama so he wanted to start the company up in Birmingham.
And we moved to Birmingham and we opened our first
outpatient center, and it looked more like a fitness center
or a spa or something and that was part of our concept was
to make it non-medical as much as possible so that the
patient feels like they are going to a spa or something
rather than getting medical treatment. We opened our first
center and it started seeing patients right away, we charged
less than the acute care hospitals and we were off and
running. And we raised additional venture capital, opened
more centers. I came in one morning, there were probably
only maybe 15 people in the corporate office and Richard had
drawn this stick figure image up here and he said look,
these guys are pulling the wagon, he said a lot of you aren'
t really hooked up, some of you are riding in the wagon,
this guy is pulling the wagon backwards, this guy is just
kind of fat and dumb sitting on the sidelines and he says I
need you to all pull the wagon. And he left that drawing up
and it became kind of a company motto, to pull the wagon.
And he had it reproduced and as years went by, it was famed
and it was in the lobby of every HealthSouth facility next
to a picture of Richard Scrushy. And at the end of the year
if you were an outstanding employee, you got 100 shares of
stock and a little red wagon and it was called Pulling The
Wagon Award. We discovered as we started to open these
outpatients centers that there was a need for rehabilitation
hospitals, specialty hospitals where you don't go for
surgery, you don't go there if you are sick, you go there if
you are really hurt or you have had a bad stroke and you
still need nursing care so you are in-patient in a hospital
but a rehab hospital. We also discovered that outpatient
surgery was becoming a big business. Years ago a physician
would not cut on you if you were not in an acute care
hospital. But as you are probably aware, things have
changed, technology has changed and a large percentage of
all surgeries now are done on outpatient basis, and we got
into that business. So we really had three basic businesses
rehab, outpatient centers, hospitals and then outpatient
surgery. We started the company in 1984 and by 1986 we were
talking to investment bankers about going public. And I
remember very well we were meeting with the bankers from
Drexel Burnham; you may not know and the older people in the
room would know about Drexel Burnham. But we were meeting
with the banker and we were discussing our numbers and
everything and he said look, you almost have a lot of
startup calls so he said, how are you handling your startup
calls? And I said well I am expensing it, very conservative
accounting, just writing it off as we incurred it. And he
looked at Richard and I and he almost had a twinkle in his
eye and he said oh no, he said you should be capitalizing
those calls. He said, I think I can get you public just as
soon as you show a profit because you have a great concept
but he said you ought to be capitalizing those expenses and
get profitable quickly and we will take you public. And
Richard looked at me and he said Aaron, why are you letting
their accounting tail wag the dog, he says your blankety
blank conservative accounting is holding us back and he said
you should be doing this. He said, I can't believe you are
hurting me, I am trying to get this company public and your
conservative accounting is holding us back. And that's kind
of how Richard managed; if he could get you down, he would
really beat on you so to speak. So I re-stated our numbers,
redid our projections and sure enough in the second quarter
of 1986 we made a profit and the banker said let's go. So we
went on a road show, we went to New York, Boston, Chicago,
San Francisco, LA all of the big institutional buyers in
these cities and we had our road show and we presented the
stock to investors. The last road show was typically in New
York City. The night before you priced the stock or the day
before at luncheon, Richard made this just outstanding
presentation and at the end of this presentation he got a
standing ovation, and the guy sitting next to him, he said I
have never seen anything like this. He said, normally people
don't applaud to these types of presentations and he says,
all my years on Wall Street I have never seen anyone get a
standing ovation. And he said, you guys should not be going
public, your company is only two years old, you top-line
[inaudible] is only $5 million, you and Richard have no
experience running a public company, there are no other
companies quite like you out there so the analysts are going
to have trouble writing research on you. But he said,
clearly you are going to go public, Richard is such a
salesman he will pull it off. Sure enough, we were priced to
go out at $8 to $10 a share and the deal got done at 650, we
barely made it, it was almost a pull at the last minute. But
we got public, began trading and it was very exciting. I was
calling my broker every 15 minutes to see how the stock was
doing and within a few months we were a $10 stock. You can
do the arithmetic I had a 100,000 shares, I am now a
millionaire. And the money changed me. As the years went by,
I bought a condo in the French Quarter, I bought a beach
house in Florida. Over the years I bought $30,000 worth of
these Hermes Neckties, they are really good looking neckties
I have to admit, but I went kind of crazy on that. And it
certainly changed Richard; Richard's ego now was on
steroids. He formed a rock and roll band called Proxy and he
began playing at company functions and even at music
festivals and nightclubs and he wanted to become a rock
star. And the band didn't do that well so he formed a
country band and he went to Nashville and he hired musicians
to back him and he actually wrote a song he called Honk If
You Love the Honky Tonk. And he sent memos out to all of our
employees asking them to call the radio stations and
recommend his song be played, and he was just unbelievable.
He also started always carrying a gun in his briefcase and
he hired bodyguards that followed him everywhere and even if
he went to Wal-Mart or whatever, his bodyguards would be
behind him speaking into their sleeves and he almost became
kind of a Hannibal Lecter type kind of person. He didn't
look little bit like Hannibal Lecter but it was just amazing
what the money did to him. In spite of this though, he was
the darling of Wall Street. He had started an entire niche
in health care and everybody wanted him on their board of
directors, venture capitalists brought him other deals to
invest in, he just absolutely was a darling of Wall Street.
And he became very wealthy. He controlled the board of
directors so when I got 10000 options he got a million that
kind of a thing. In 1995 less than 10 years after starting
the company I estimated from his publicly owned stock in
HealthSouth and other companies he was worth $600 million.
And he told the Birmingham News newspaper that he wanted to
be a billionaire and he was well on his way. That was his
goal to be as rich as he could be, to be a billionaire.
HealthSouth did very well, we did lots of public offerings,
about six companies went public in the same business we were
in and we began buying up our competitors. We did pooling of
interest, we would buy their stock with our stock and by
1995, we were the largest company in Alabama, State of
Alabama, we were operating in all 50 states, we had 50,000
employees, we were a Fortune 500 Company and I was a rock-
star in Birmingham. I could go into any restaurant and
people would point at me, want to talk to me, it was just
amazing. And it was quite the lifestyle. We started buying
jet airplanes, we had two Gulfstream airplanes which were
about $30 million airplanes. Many mornings, Richard and I
would go to our hanger, get on our Gulfstream to whatever
stirred us, cook us breakfast as we flew in Teterboro
Airport, New Jersey. We would get off the airplane, there
would be a helicopter waiting for us, we would get on the
helicopter, fly into Manhattan, there would be a limo
waiting for us. We would go to the Plaza Hotel where Charlie
Sheen hangs out and make presentations to investors and then
fly back home that night, never going through Atlanta or
anything. It was really quite the lifestyle. Richard's
obsession with being wealthy was unbelievable and he was the
one that really talked to the analysts and investment
bankers about what kind of earnings we could achieve. And he
understood that his wealth was tied to Wall Street. And he
would ask the analysts what do we need to do for you ought
to keep a strong buy on the stock and they would tell him,
you need to grow 30% whatever and he said we can do that.
Everything was okay for the first 7, 8, 9 years, we would
hit those what he can promised to the Street. But it got
difficult. We were a big company now, there weren't as many
growth opportunities and just compound growth of 20%-30% is
difficult to achieve year after year after year. So we
started doing some not-so-good accounting. In health care
the biggest issue, the trick is revenue recognition which it
is in many businesses. You have contracts with HMOs,
Medicare, private companies, you have lot of bad debt so
what you charge the patient and what you eventually collect
are very different. So you have to make adjustments to that
revenue to come up with a net receivable number that's a
good number. As it became difficult to make our numbers
maybe we mistreat estimates by a penny, we would say now
maybe bad debts aren't 10% of revenue they are going to be
8% and we would change our basis for the accounting for bad
debts. Not fraud but certainly not good accounting. For
those of you who are accounting majors you understand you
don't change your underlying accounting principles to
achieve a number, you change those principles when it really
dictates the circumstances that say you should. But we did
it to make our numbers. Everything was fine until 1996, 10
years of being a public company. And we had completed our
second quarter and we had missed our numbers really badly
and the Street was picking up that our days
[inaudible] were growing, our cash flow didn't seem to be
what it should be and Bill Owens who was my chief accountant
now just felt like we could not play with the reserves
anymore, it would be too transparent and it was time to
report a bad quarter. We went into Richard's office and we
showed him the numbers and we told him and he said no, have
you guys lost your minds, he said we can't do that, he said
the analysts are going to put sales on the stock, it's going
to crash, we are going to be sued by stockholders, your
stock options are going to be worthless, you are not going
to be the rock stars in Birmingham anymore. He said we can't
do that. And he said look, and he is a cold bloke, he put on
his salesman hat and he said now look, health care is the
biggest business in the United States, we are a small part
of it. He said, we can get into the acute care hospital
business and become if not the largest one of the largest
companies in the country but he said I can't do it if you
all screw this up by reporting these bad numbers. And he
said you have all done things to the numbers before you know
capitalizing calls, changing estimates, he said there's got
to be something you can do to get us past this little bump
in the road. And Bill Owens who was my chief accountant who
had worked for auditors said Richard, he said look, we have
1500 general ledgers, he said I can make entries small
enough that the auditors won't look at them, and he was very
clear he said, I will be crediting revenue that don't exist
and debiting assets that don't exist. I was intimidated by
Richard, I am ashamed to admit it but I did not have the
courage to stand up to him at that point. I knew he had a
gun in his briefcase, I had seen him get so angry about
small things that I could not think of causing his net worth
to go down by several hundred million dollars. And I
believed in the company, we were a good company, and I
wanted a part of it to keep going on and I will be honest
with you I did not want to report bad numbers either. So
that night Bill Owens cooked the books. I told my wife about
it when I went home and she told me how stupid I was and
that night of course I couldn't sleep. I woke up the next
day and I felt like I had to put a genie back in the bottle
and of course I couldn't and that point in my life changed
and I was now living a lie, we had cooked the books. The
next quarters rolls around and we do it again, not quite as
difficult the second time. 1996 ends, I lie to the auditors
when they ask sort of standard questions about, have any
interest been made or not made that should have been made
and sure enough, we got it by the auditors and it wasn't
discovered. 1997 begins and we plead with Richard to lower
Street expectations and he had no part it. He knew that once
you are a high PE, high growth company, once you tell the
Street you are not going to keep growing, they will put
sales or lease holds on the stock rather than strong buys.
So we began 1997 and it was apparent to me that we were
going to have another year of cooking the books because we
were in a hole, we had to get out of the hole and then grow
unrealistically. During this period of time I think it was
early 1997, Richard told Bill Owens and I, he said if we are
ever caught, I will deny everything. You guys do what you
want but I am telling you I am going to deny everything.
Well my life is an utter mess. I am beginning to drink more
than I should, I hate my job, I hate going to work everyday
and I felt trapped and I didn't want to be a whistleblower.
With Richard making that statement, I knew he would bring
more lawyers, guns and money to the party than I would, I
didn't want to stay because it was not fun anymore, it was
all a lie. So I went to Richard and I told him I wanted to
retire and I was only 54 years old and he said, if that's
what you want to do, he said I think you are making a
mistake but if that's what you want to do, and we never
talked about the fraud and Richard is very smart, you don't
have to spell things out to him. So I left the company in
1997 and I moved to South Alabama Coast and about as soon as
I was not an insider anymore, I sold lot of my stock and I
bought 25 acres of land and I built a very nice house and
for some reason I built a football field in my backyard and
to this day I don't know of anyone else that built, I mean
had a goalpost and everything. And I just distanced myself
from the company I just put it out of my mind. But one day
about a year after I retired Richard called me and said come
to Birmingham, have lunch with me. So I went to Birmingham
and went into the dining room of the corporate offices and
he said look Aaron, I need you to come back to work. He said
that we are making our numbers fine now, he said everything
is okay, you need to come back and help me grow the company.
And I told him no, I really did not want to get back into
the frying pan and I was having lot of fun with my dogs and
my football field. So I went back and 1998 passes 1999,
2000, 2001, 2002 but in the spring of 2003 I am watching the
evening news and they open up with we have a breaking story
out of Birmingham Alabama, massive accounting fraud
uncovered at HealthSouth, billions of bogus entries have
been made to the books and I was like God. When I first
retired, every time my doorbell rang or my phone rang, I
thought it was FBI but it had been 6 years and I wanted to
believe the fraud had stopped. So I am sure I wasn't as
surprised as the average guy on the street but I was amazed
that the fraud had gone on all those years. Alice Martin who
was the attorney with the federal government out of the
Northern District of Alabama in the newspaper the next day
said several people have come forward, admitted their
involvement in the fraud but there are others that are
involved and if you are one of those people, you need to
come forward and I almost thought she was going to name me
by name in paper. But my wife tried to console me and say
look, you have been gone a long time and the fraud wasn't
that big when you were there, they are not going to come
after you, and I said I don't think so. So I contacted an
attorney, a white collar criminal attorney and he knew Alice
Martin's people, he made some phone calls and he called me
back and he said oh yeah, Mr. Beam you need to come talk to
me. So my wife and I went in and the first thing he said, he
says do not lie to me and do not lie to the federal
government. He says your former employees have told them you
were involved, the FBI is all over that building, and if you
lie, they are going to come down on you like a freight
train, you need to tell the truth. By now my wife is in
tears, I am almost in tears and I have a kind of funny sense
of humor, I asked him if he needed a check or something and
he said yes, I would like for you to write me a check for
$100,000. I said you got to be kidding. He said no, Mr.
Beam, I am not kidding, he said that won't be the last check
you are going to have to write. And I asked him if I could
get a t-shirt or something and he gave me a coffee mug and
my wife and I refer to it as a $100,000 coffee mug. Three
days later I am in a federal building in Birmingham Alabama
and I am sitting across the table from two FBI agents, two
agents from the SEC, several attorneys from Alice Martin's
office and I wasn't scared but it is not fun to be
interrogated by the FBI and the SEC. And I felt like I didn'
t do a good job because they wanted to know in 1996 when you
first cooked the books what did you say to Richard, what did
he say to you and they were recording all this and I couldn'
t remember, I couldn't remember details. But at the end of
the day, it lasted all day, FBI agent said Mr. Beam he said
we know a lot about this case and from what we know we
believe you were very truthful today and he said we
appreciate that. Alice Martin's people said 17 people have
come forward admitted their involvement in the fraud only
one key person denies it, Richard Scrushy, he says he knows
nothing about it and we are going to have take Mr. Scrushy
to trial and we will like for you to be a witness. And they
explained that they weren't cutting me a deal that it wasn't
like rat Richard up and you don't go to prison, all we can
tell you that if you cooperate, we recommend our senate, to
a federal judge, we will ask him to take that into
consideration. This is the spring of 2002 the trial didn't
began until '05 in January. So I had a two year period where
my life was literally very, very miserable. I knew I could
possibly go to prison for north of 20 years basically rest
of my life. And my attorney explained to me that they are
going to look at your personal balance sheet and because of
the magnitude of the fraud, they can fine you whatever they
want to fine you. And they are not going to put in a box
underneath a freeway but you are not going to have a
football field and a million dollar home and a home in
Florida and all that, you are going to have to sell that in
order to pay the government. So like I say it was very, very
dark period of time. During this period of time, Richard
Scrushy went on the offensive. He left the church that he
belonged to and he joined an intercity church and he gave
that church a million dollars. He also bought a television
station in Birmingham and he and his wife every morning
Monday through Friday preached the gospel on TV and he was a
preacher. He spent $20 million on his lawyers. He hired a
jury selection firm, he had a publicist and all during the
trial everyday he always had a Bible in his hand, he and his
wife and he was surrounded by ministers. I thought it was
laughable, it was so obvious what he was trying to do I just
didn't think it would work. The government wanted me to be
the first witness, there were four CFOs after I left all
promoted up in the company, and they wanted me to be the
first because they thought I was very professor-like, I
guess it was the beard I don't know and that I could explain
to the jury what street estimates were, what are earnings
for share, what's the balance sheet, what's an income
statement. And sure enough they put me on the stand and they
had charts and it goes on almost all day and the jury is
falling asleep. I am trying to make eye contact and they
don't get it, they are bored, they don't understand it, they
literally were falling asleep. I could have been teaching
rocket science or brain surgery, they would pick up on it
just as well what I was doing. Now this is big time
courtroom drama. This was the first Sarbanes-Oxley case
tried in the United States and it was a big deal. And you
don't want to be involved in something like this if you don'
t have to. Very first thing the lawyer gets in my face, he
says Mr. Beam, you have had an extramarital affair, haven't
you, and I said yes, because I had. The next day the
Birmingham News, the newspaper said what a clever attorney
he was to get me to admit to this. And the next day my wife
wanted to come to the courtroom holding our son saying she
still loved me and we have been married 40 years now and I
have since discovered that he was on his fourth wife and the
fourth wife is very much a trophy
[inaudible]. He then gets in my face, he says Mr. Beam when
you went to New York City and presented to investors, you
lied, didn't you, when you presented the numbers to the
board of directors you lied, Mr. Beam you lie so much, you
don't know when you are telling the truth, you are a cheat
and a liar. The jurors' eyes were this big, they were awake,
they were having fun, this was entertainment to have this
lawyer scream at me and call me a liar. The trial went on
for six months, the jury deliberated for about 6 weeks, not
guilty all charges. The legal community throughout the
United States could not believe it. Enron, WorldCom, Tyco,
Martha Stewart, they all went to prison but not Richard
Scrushy. Within a couple of weeks he flew to Houston Texas
to coach Ken Lay on how to conduct his trial at Enron, it
was unbelievable. They asked the jury, some of the ones that
were willing to talk, they asked them how did you find Mr.
Scrushy not guilty when 17 people, 5 CFOs all said he was at
the center of the fraud? And some of them said well it
seemed like those CFOs were liars and Mr. Scrushy seemed
like a nice Christian man. I cried like a baby when the
verdict went out, I just could not believe that he had
pulled it off. Three months later I was sent to a federal
person and I got only three months and I don't understand
why I got such a light sentence but I
[inaudible] and I did not volunteer to do more time. I don't
know if any of you all have been to prison but if you got to
go to prison, you want to go to a federal minimum security
prison. It's not that bad. My wife drove me there, I
reported, it was on an air force base and you are not locked
up per se and they actually tell you if you want to leave
you can but they say when the marshals, US marshals catch
you, you are going to big boy prison, and I didn't want to
go to big boy prison so. Interesting place, prisons like
this were initially set up I think for white collar
criminals. And there were a lot of lawyers and accountants.
There was, two beds down from me where we slept there was a
thoracic surgeon that had cheated the Medicare problem. The
most interesting guy I met while I was there was the father
of the young man that just married Chelsea Clinton. He was a
politician and he was in for seven years for I think
embezzling the campaign funds or something, a nice guy, very
interesting. About half of the prison thought was drug
dealers. If you are not a non violent drug dealer and you
get less than 10 years you can go to this kind of person.
So, it was kind of a 50-50 white collar and drug dealers. I
was there during football season and I am a big LSU fan and
did I tell you, I think we were going to pay a ball game.
One night LSU was playing and it was on TV and there is a
television set in the lobby where you are housed and up
until 10 o'clock at night you can watch television. So I
went in to watch the game and there were a bunch of drug
dealers and there they were watching the Miami Hurricane.
And they called me pops, they said no pops, you are not
watching your tigers, we are going to watch our
[inaudible]. And I was depressed. I went around every
barrack trying to find a TV which you are not supposed to do
to watch the game and all the drug dealers had
[inaudible]. The season ends, LSU gets an invitation to go
to the Peach Bowl in Atlanta, Georgia, to play the Miami
Hurricanes. So I said oh boy, I m going to get to see this
game. The night before the game three of these guys came to
me and they are biggest football players because they are in
and out of prison and they lift weights and they are huge,
and they ask me for my shoelaces, and I said why. They said
so you won't hang yourself when Miami kicks LSU's ass
tomorrow. So the game begins. It's me and 30 drug dealers
from Miami and LSU wins 40 to 3 and it was absolutely the
most fun you can possibly can while you are in prison. The
worst thing about it there was nobody there with violence in
their background. So the first night I took a shower I
looked over my shoulder and nothing happened. But the worst
part was the food. I happened to read the book Fast Food
Nation while I was in there and it talked about how the very
worst grade of all food goes to prisons. And after being
there about a week I got the right to call my wife and I
called her and I told her, I was telling her how bad the
food was and she said Aaron, you are in prison. So I didn't
complain about the food anymore. I got out in February and I
am now a felon. Do you know what the job market is like for
felons? It's not good. You can imagine in today's job market
if there is a good job opening there's got to be 30, 40, 50
people that qualify for applying. What chance does a felon
have? So I needed a job and my fines and my legal bills were
well in excess of a million dollars and I had to auction off
my property and I needed a job. My wife had gone back to
work. I had always liked gardening and working outdoors. And
I went back to school and I got a two year certificate in
turf management and for the past two years I have been
making a living mowing lawns. It's not that bad except the
heat in South Alabama during summer is just terrible. But
when I was at HealthSouth and my salary was $500,000, I
really didn't feel like I was earning that money, there were
50,000 employees out there making that money for me. But
today when I mow lawns and I cut somebody's grass and I get
maybe $40 or $50 in South Alabama heat, I feel like I have
really earned that money. I do sleep better now than I ever
did when I was at HealthSouth. My wife is so smart she said
Aaron, why don't you call the dean of the business school,
over the years I have given them a lot of money, and see if
you could talk to the MBA students about what has happened
to you. And I do like talking so I called the dean and the
dean said yeah, I think that would be a good idea. So, I
went to talk to the MBA students, they had a special session
for me and it went very well. I really felt like I had done
something right. But I didn't think about doing speaking as
a living, doing it for a living. Enron, WorldCom, Tyco,
HealthSouth it all faded into the woodwork and they weren't
front page news anymore. But something happened, you all
might have heard about the Subprime Debacle. We learned that
millions of loans were made to people, mortgage companies
coached people how to lie on their loan applications to be
able to buy a home they really couldn't afford. Wall Street
took those loans, packaged to them, got them rated very
highly, standard
[inaudible] and they told the investing public these were
good securities. On the other side of the house their hedge
funds were short in these securities. The real estate bubble
burst and all of a sudden, I mean just almost overnight, you
have lived it, the largest insurance companies, the largest
banks, the largest investment banking firms are all broke
and they are asking for bailout and we are in the great
recession. Why? At the heart of it is greed and unethical
business behavior. HealthSouth was bad but this was massive
so massive that it put the whole world into a recession, the
great recession. When Webster first published its
dictionary, he defined success as being generous,
prosperous, healthy and kind. Today, that definition is the
attainment of wealth, fame and rank. Having a bigger house
and more cars than your neighbor and you are up to here in
debt is not being successful particularly if you accumulate
that wealth by doing unethical business things. So I have
been speaking to colleges and companies and associations,
fraud associations and accounting groups about ethics. And
you might say and I am sure you have said this, you can't
teach ethic, you are either ethical or you are not. I don't
believe it's just black or white, I believe it's like the
pilot that landed that plane on the Hudson River. He studied
every crash, every water landing and he knew in those
critical moments exactly what to do and how to bring that
plane in and save those people's lives. I think today if we
teach ethics at high schools, colleges, on the job, you will
be better prepared to deal with the kind of things I had to
deal with and trust me, you will when you get out into the
business world, you will face things like I faced maybe not
as big but you will be asked to keep sales open a little
longer
[inaudible] maybe cut payables off a little early to help
the bottom line. I think the image of the accountant with a
green visor in the backroom is for a large part true. The
card charging people are in sales, they are in marketing,
they are out front they like confrontation. Accountants like
to kind of be in the background and please people by keeping
a nice set of books, and that hurts you. The largest
turnover of executives in the United States is CFOs. CFO of
public companies only last 31/2 years and part of it is
because they are constantly asked to make the numbers what
they need to be and it's really, really a big problem and
you need to be aware of that. When you go to work for a
company and you figure out you have got a sociopath at the
top
[inaudible] and the tone of the top is all wrong, you need
to leave that company and go to another company. There is a
professor at Arizona State University Dr. Marianne Jennings
and she is probably one of the outstanding ethics professors
in United States and she has written a book called the Seven
Signs of Ethical Collapse and the book is about Enron,
WorldCom, Tyco and HealthSouth. And she talks about the
seven things to look for in a company before it has a
complete ethical meltdown. The first sign is the pressure to
maintain the numbers, make the numbers, and at HealthSouth
that was our whole focus make the numbers no matter what,
make the numbers. But if the culture is such that it's make
the numbers with no regard for doing it ethically, doing it
correctly, that's the first sign. The second sign is fear
and silence. Richard managed by intimidation and most people
don't want to tell their boss, they are afraid they will
lose their job so there is a culture of fear and silence in
these companies. You might think my whole speech today is
bashing of Richard Scrushy which you have got to realize
that when you have an Enron or WorldCom or HealthSouth, the
guy at the top, the CEO is probably a bigger than life
personality who hires young people or people that he can
control and manage and intimidate and get them to do what he
wants. The fourth sign is weak board of directors and this
is probably the most important, certainly back in the
HealthSouth era. Dr. Jennings said that HealthSouth had the
weakest board of directors she had ever seen. Just
absolutely any time Richard put somebody on the board and
they gave him any trouble he just got rid of them. So over
the years he just developed a board of yes men. The board at
WorldCom was referred to as Bernie's Boys, Bernie Ebbers was
the chairman of the board and these were the boys. Conflict,
Richard made sure we all had stock options, we were given
loans to exercise our stock options, we did business with
our board members. We bought $8 million worth of glass from
a guy to go into our hospitals who was on the board. So
Richard set us up to be conflicted so we would stay true to
the calls. Innovation like no other; I would challenge
anybody in this room to explain to us what Enron really did,
nobody understood Enron's business, they had this unique
business. The unique thing like no other thing at
HealthSouth was our earnings. For 10 years, we were
perfectly straight no bumps at all. People sometime look
hard at companies when they are doing badly but all of these
companies Enron, HealthSouth, they were high flying
companies apparently doing very well, too well. The last
sign is goodness in some areas atones for evil in other
areas. It's kind of an interesting sign but it's there in
many cases. HealthSouth gave lots of money to churches and
schools and everything. There were many, many things
throughout the State of Alabama with Richard Scrushy's name
on it, it was HealthSouth money but he made sure he gave
money to these causes and he was recognized as this very
generous person. One last Richard Scrushy story because it's
the best one, Richard has had three wives and nine children
and his third wife was a graduate of Troy University in
South Alabama. And they wanted to get into division one
football and they needed to sell x number of season tickets
and they needed to enlarge their stadium. So HealthSouth
bought the tickets and gave them the money to enlarge the
stadium and sure enough it became the Richard M. Scrushy
stadium. But he also required that the band play his song,
Honk if you Like the Honky Tonk, unbelievable. I have
written a book called HealthSouth: The Wagon to Disaster and
you might say oh look at Aaron Beam, he is up here preaching
to us about ethics and he is trying to get rich off of a
book he wrote. I don't know how many of you have written a
book. You might have doctor but the chances of you writing a
book and you becoming wealthy from it is about as likely as
you being struck by lightening while you are on your
honeymoon with Cindy Crawford, this is not going to happen.
My speech is a condensed version of the book and that's the
reason I wrote the book. I hope universities will have
students read it so that they can understand how this all
evolved, how I got on the slippery slope and how I made the
terrible decisions that I did. Today, I am a felon, that's
all I am ever going to be remembered as. I am not going to
be remembered as a guy that started one of the largest
health care companies, involved in the largest companies in
Alabama, I am going to be known as a guy that cooked the
books of HealthSouth. You do not want to go there. All the
unethical behavior is very corrosive, it's like metal
rusting. One day it rusts more and more and more and the
bridge falls down and people die. If you let yourself
compromise your ethnical principles, it will lead to a very
bad ending and that's the message I want to bring today. At
this point I would like to throw it open to questions. Does
anybody have any question?
[Audience]
He is in prison, believe it or not. This was his mug shot
when he went to prison. After the government lost the case
of HealthSouth he was indicted for bribing the Governor of
Alabama. The governor was running for reelection while he
was at HealthSouth and he gave the governor or HealthSouth
gave the governor $500,000 for his campaign funds. Richard
got appointed to a board, a CON Certificate of Need board, a
public state position and the federal government said this
was a bribe. The legal community said this is silly, people
give politicians money all the time and it's seldom ever
considered a bribe, it is just not. Well Richard fired up
his TV show, he got the bibles back out, got the ministers
in the courtroom and he was found guilty. He is in a prison
is Beaumont Texas now and he has been there for 3 years and
he is doing seven years. I think he got one year knocked
off. They have asked him what is he going to do when he gets
out and he said he is going to continue preaching and he is
going to write and sing Christian music so you all get in
line for that album when it comes out. I have had no contact
with him, don't want to. I hope he lives by the rules you
can't own a gun when you are a felon.
[Audience]
Well we were in a bubble, a stock market bubble in
particularly health care stocks and part of it was just like
the mortgage thing, you rationalize that it's okay.
[Audience]
No, and it really didn't, maybe toward the end it got down
to patient care level but it was pretty much in the
boardroom. And the day we did it, we cooked the books, you
don't think about the consequences, you don't look ahead and
think oh my God this is going to turn out very terrible. You
rationalize it, you believe you are doing the best choice,
you are picking the best option about doing what you do.
White collar criminals are like that. I met an FBI agent at
a conference the other day and he was very clear, the
typical criminal that holds up a bank with a gun, the money
is in the bank and he wants it, okay; the white collar
criminal though many times rationalizes and convinces
himself that what you are doing is not really bad and if you
can pull if off, what the heck.
[Audience]
All of our accounting was centralized so people sent all
their financial information, payrolls and everything was
done centrally. So Bill Owens was a very smart guy and he
was able to do it. How he pulled it off for all those years
I don't know. The forensic accounting bill to clean up the
books was $643 million dollars so there were literally
hundreds of thousands of bogus entries made. How the
auditors did not catch it, I don't know. I wasn't surprised
that they didn't catch it the first year I was there but how
it went on, the last audited balance sheet had 300 million
in cash that didn't exist. So they weren't real good
auditors.
[Audience]
You really should. Certainly if you know it's fraudulent,
you know it's fraud, you should report it and you could be
rewarded handsomely. The new
[inaudible] bill, I think you get 30% of the fine that
ultimately goes down so. There is a lot of controversy
around that whether or not that's a good piece of
legislation or not but you certainly should, you should
tell. But it takes a lot of courage. The easy thing to do is
just walk away but if you know for sure that there is out
and there is hotlines and ways you can do it and not be
known.
[Audience]
The 2010 Aaron Beam is a lot smarter than he was back then.
I would have said no Richard we can't do this, this is
pushing the envelope too far, this is fraud, this is wrong.
And he would have fired me, I would have lost my job but I
should have done that and I would do it today. You get
religion when you go to prison.
[Audience]
The trick with a person like Richard is that the personality
type of a CEO, a real hard charging CEO has a lot of the
traits that Richard has. You just need to size them up and
make sure that they are not a sociopath because clearly if
Richard can sue me for anything is probably me calling him
sociopath but he is, he has no conscience, and you have to
figure that out. But you look at the people, look at Donald
Trump, I mean he loves himself, he loves being on reality
TV, everybody wants to go to work for Donald. I am not
saying Donald Trump is Richard Scrushy but Richard had the
Donald Trump type personality of loving himself.
[Audience]
Bill Owens got 5 years, Weston Smith who actually wrote
chapter 10 in my book he got two years, Mike Martin the CFO
that replaced me got 3 years but really kind of life
sentences. If you plead, if you come forward and plead then
the government does have to take you to court ,you do get a
lot better deal. All of those guys, myself, if I had tried
to lie through it and they had found me guilty, I probably
would have gone to prison for many, many, many years.
[Audience]
Okay thank you.